forget about the iphone 7 for a moment
Apple kicked off its big event by
finally bringing one of the most beloved
video game characters to the App Store
eat some audio Nintendo Shigeru Miyamoto
took the stage to show off super mario
run which will arrive before the end of
the year but the games weren't over
Pokemon go is coming to the Apple watch
just one more excuse to explore the
world with your face buried in the
screen seriously though nearly two years
after Apple first introduced its watch
to the world we have the follow up they
call it series to the brighter faster
smarter watch at last comes with GPS so
you don't need to take your phone with
you to track your run it's also
water-resistant for swimming laps at the
pool apple also partnered with Nike to
develop a version of the watch
specifically for runners pricing is 369
for both the series 2 and the Nike Plus
version the original apple watch gets a
new processor and now starts at 269
pre-orders start September 9th with the
watch's shipping the following week it's
the best iPhone that we have ever
created we would hope so yeah the iphone
7 is faster it comes with louder
speakers a more sensitive home button
longer battery life and its water and
dust-resistant but the biggest leap
forward has got to be the camera it's
got optical image stabilization and a
wider aperture the sensor is also sixty
percent faster and thirty percent more
efficient but with the iphone 7 plus
there really is a plus a second camera
that's right it comes with two side by
side 12 megapixel cameras one's a wide
angle and the other a telephoto all this
is so you can zoom in without quality
distortion and take a close-up photo
with some nice depth of field the
headphone jack is sadly gone some people
have asked why we would remove
the analog headphone jack well the
reason to move on it really comes down
to one word courage what it really means
is you'll have to use headphones with
apples Lightning port or purchase
wireless earbuds like Apple's new air
pods if you really can't let go of the
analog Jack Apple will include a free
adapter in your iphone 7 box so prices
and availability the new iphone 7 starts
at six 49 and great news Apple is
doubling the storage pre-orders start
September 9th and phones begin shipping
September 16th the new air pods will be
available in late October and we'll go
for 159 proof that was a lot from Apple
thankfully we had to see a sinus off
with a giant bow